[MUSIC PLAYING]
ETSUJI NAKAI: I'm really happy
to see many people in this room
now, even though
this is the morning
session of the last day.
[LAUGHTER]
And especially I see some
really enthusiastic people
in the front row.
And in this session,
I will talk,
a little bit, practical aspects
of machine learning projects.
So if you are actually working
on some real machine learning
projects, I hope you
will find something
useful for your project
in this session.
OK, anyway, I'm Etsuji Nakai.
I'm a Solutions Architect
for Google Cloud Platform.
I'm based in Tokyo.
And in this session, I will talk
about the continuous deployment
in machine learning.
So what does it mean?
The concept of
continuous deployment
is fairly common
today, especially
in the field of
web applications.
So for comparison, let's think
about the very traditional
enterprise business
application project.
In that case, once
you have successfully
launched your initial version
of your business application,
it is basically the
end of the story.
It's really a happy
ending of your project.
However, if this is a project
of the modern web application,
especially for
consumer users, you
know the situation is different,
because the requirements
from end users, especially
from consumer users,
are always changing.
So to keep up with
the changing reality,
you have to keep upgrading
your application.
Sometimes you have to introduce
new technology to change
your application completely.
So basically you have to
keep deploying new versions
of your application forever.
This is a basic concept
of continuous deployment
in web applications.
And I'll say the same
concept can be, or should be,
applied to machine
learning projects.
So let me start
with explaining what
continuous deployment means
in machine learning projects.
And this is a very common
imagination about machine
learning among many people.
I don't think it's
you, [LAUGHS] but still
many people believe
that machine learning
is a magical
mathematical algorithm.
You have some data, you put
those data into the algorithm,
then you have a magical result.
Of course it's illusion.
[LAUGHS]
As you know, the real machine
learning project, especially
the end-to-end process
of machine learning
involves a lot of human effort.
First of all, you have to
collect your training data
and organize them with
some big data too,
like BigQuery or
Cloud Dataflow on GCP.
And then you need to
employ data scientists
to build machine learning model
according to your training
data.
And then you use a bunch
of computing resources,
like Cloud Machine
Learning Engine on GCP,
to train your machine
learning model.
And finally, [LAUGHS] you
can deploy the trained model
to the real world
as an API service
or as in the back-end side
with a real machine learning
applications.
And the good news is that you
have a lot of useful tools
to support this end-to-end
machine learning process
on GCP.
And I think you have heard of
these tools in other sessions.
However, in this session I don't
talk about these tools at all.
[LAUGHS] The main
focus of this session
is about feedback, because
the goal of machine learning
is to predict something
in the real world.
And as you know, the real
world is always changing.
So you need to have some
feedback from the real world
to upgrade your
machine learning model,
to keep the freshness of
your machine learning model.
Now, the question is how and
why feedback or the freshness
is important in
machine learning.
So let me use this
very simple example
to explain why freshness matters
in machine learning models.
This is a tutorial article.
The title is "Machine Learning
with Structured Data."
I published this
article this year,
so you can find this article
by searching with these titles.
And in this article,
I explained how
you can build machine learning
model to predict babies weight.
On the left side of the screen
using an example application,
you specify some attributes
of pregnant person,
and by clicking
the predict button,
you can make a prediction about
the newborn baby's weight,
babies who will be born
in the near future,
like in 2018 or 2019.
I think this model has
some realistic use case.
I believe some doctors can
use this machine learning
model for some medical purpose.
But anyway, in this article,
I used the open public data
set called the Natality
Data Set to train
this machine learning model.
It is available for
everyone on BigQuery.
It is birth records
in the United States
from 1969 to 2008, and it
contains more than 100 million
records.
[LAUGHS] So in a
sense, it is big data.
It contains data for
nearly 40 years--
very good.
But let's look at a
snippet of the SQL
to extract our trend
data from BigQuery.
As you can see,
the WHERE clause,
I didn't use the whole 40 years
data to train this model--
I used only data after 2001.
So what's the problem with
using the whole data to train
this machine learning model?
And the answer is
data freshness,
because the goal
of this model is,
as I told you, to predict
a baby's weight who will be
born in near future, in 2018.
So naturally thinking,
using fairly old data,
like in the '70s, to
train this machine
learning model may not
be good for that purpose,
because environments
surrounding people in the '70s
could be totally
different from today.
So I did some experiment.
First, I trained this
machine learning model
with the data in fairly
old days, like in the '70s.
And then I tested it against
the relatively new test data
in 2008.
And the result was
1.21 RMS error.
What does it mean?
It means the predictions
of this model
are different from
the ground truth,
different from of actual
value, in average, 1.21 pounds.
Is it good or bad?
Of course, to understand
it, you have to compare.
So then I trained the same
model with relatively new data
from 2001 to 2008
and again tested
with the same test set in 2008.
And the result was
1.05 RMS error.
So obviously, this result is
better than the previous one.
That's the reason why I used
data only after 2001 to train
this machine learning model.
Very good.
Make sense?
However, this is not
the end of the story.
Now, suppose that I'm
really serious about using
this machine learning
model in the real world.
I want to provide this machine
learning model to real doctors.
In that case, I have to validate
this machine learning model
against the latest
data, like in 2018.
Unfortunately, the
open Natality Data Set
did not have the data in
2018, so I couldn't test it.
But naturally thinking,
because this model
was trained with
the data until 2008,
the test result
against 2018 test data
might be worse than
the previous one.
So basically, if you are really
serious about using machine
learning model in the real
world for practical purposes,
you have to keep collecting
new data forever.
And sometimes you have to
retrain your machine learning
model with fresh data to keep
the freshness of your machine
learning model.
So this is the basic idea
of the continuous deployment
in machine learning.
And the next
question is, how you
can apply this concept in
your machine learning project.
What is the standard process
of continuous deployment
in machine learning?
What is the best practice?
So to explain that today,
I prepared 1, 2, 3--
three user stories.
And the first two stories
are just imaginary ones.
You may think these are
really unnatural situations--
I admit it.
But at least I hope through
these imaginary stories
you will understand what is the
standard process of applying
continuous deployment
and what is
the value of continuous
deployment in machine learning.
And the last one is
a real user story.
Today I'm really happy to invite
[? Kazusa-san. ?] He's working
for BrainPad-- it is a machine
learning partner in Tokyo.
He has a lot of experience of
managing real machine learning
projects.
He will talk about
his experience--
how and why
continuous deployment
is very important
in his projects, how
he applies continuous deployment
in his real projects-- later.
But anyway, let me start
with an imaginary story.
And for this story, I prepared
a fairly simple example
application.
It is a handwritten
digit recognizer.
You can draw some number
on the word canvas
and by clicking the
prediction button,
the model recognizes
what the number is--
very simple.
And now suppose that there
is an imaginary company.
The CEO wants to release this
application to the real world
and make some money.
And as I told you, we have
two imaginary stories.
The first one is very bad.
They will make a silly mistake.
However, the important
thing is to understand
why such a silly
mistake had happened
and how they could have
avoided it by applying
the continuous deployment.
OK, so let's start
the first story.
Please welcome the CEO of the
imaginary company, Nori-san
on the stage.
[APPLAUSE]
[INAUDIBLE]
NORIHIRO SHIMODA: Hi, nice
to meet you, everyone.
I'm Nori.
So I've just started
my new company,
and I've created
a super fancy app
using a machine learning model.
But I have a problem.
So I'm not sure how
much data we should
correct to train a machine
learning model appropriately.
So my team had worked
very hard to correct
the initial set of
the training data,
but I still don't know
if it's enough or not.
So I hired a funky wannabe
data scientist, so it's Yaboo.
[LAUGHTER]
So fortunately, he
had a brilliant idea
to evaluate our
machine learning model.
So Yaboo, please
tell me the details.
YABOO OYABU: Hi everyone.
My name is Yaboo, and I'm a
funky wannabe data scientist.
So to make success in
machine learning project,
I read super-advanced
machine learning textbook.
And according to it, you need to
split your data set to training
data set and test set.
[LAUGHTER]
It's very simple.
The first, you should train
your machine learning model
with training data
set and by data model,
your test set so that your
machine learning model will not
[INAUDIBLE] to training data.
Actually, I've already
done it for you,
and I got perfect results.
We got 100% accuracy here.
[LAUGHTER]
This is super nice, right?
And we should deploy this
machine learning model
so as soon as possible
to our application.
So what do you think, Nori?
NORIHIRO SHIMODA: Oh my god!
I can't believe it!
[LAUGHTER]
So, nice work, Yaboo.
I don't have any reason not
to release this application.
OK, let's launch it.
ETSUJI NAKAI: OK, thank
you, Nori-san and Yaboo-san.
You are good performers.
[APPLAUSE]
Now, on the surface, they
did a fairly good job.
They achieved a brilliant
result, perfect accuracy.
And of course, they
made a mistake.
So let me show you
what would happen
if they launched this
application to the real world.
Can you turn to the
demonstration screen?
Hello, can you turn
to the demonstration--
OK.
This is the handwritten digit
recognizer that they launched.
So let me try.
I drew a number 0.
Make a prediction.
OK, it's working.
Great.
Let me try number 1.
It's strange.
[LAUGHS] Let me try number 2.
OK.
[LAUGHTER]
It doesn't work.
So I tell you what had
happened under the covers.
So can you turn back
to the presentation?
OK.
This is the data--
[LAUGHTER]
--they used to train their
machine learning model
and evaluate it.
They have only 0's.
So that's why that model
recognized everything
as 0's, but at the
same time, they
achieved a perfect accuracy
against this test set.
Some of you may think
this is a very funny,
unrealistic situation.
It is partially correct
and partially wrong.
I can say that a
very similar thing
could happen in the real
machine learning project.
As you know, sometimes
you think you
have a lot of data to
train machine learning
model, especially very complex
deep learning model-appropriate
[INAUDIBLE], big data.
Great.
And you achieved a very good
accuracy against the test set.
However, if those data do
not reflect the real world,
it doesn't make any sense.
It doesn't won't work
in the real world.
So the question is, how you can
detect such a silly situation,
how you can avoid it, how you
can mitigate the situation.
That is continuous deployment.
So to explain and to make
the scenario a little bit
interesting, I would
have some assumption.
Now, suppose that they keep
collecting data every day.
On the first day, day one, how
much just 0's, unfortunately.
But next day, they
have 0's and 1's.
Next day, on the
third day, day three,
they have 0's, 1's and 2's.
So by keeping collecting
new data every day,
they come closer and
closer to the reality.
And on the last
day, on day 10, they
have the complete data set,
reflecting the real world
completely.
So based on this
assumption, let's see
the next good scenario.
They will apply the concept
of continuous deployment
in your project and
detect the problem.
I will mitigate the problem.
So now please welcome the
CEO of the imaginary company,
Nori-san, again on the stage.
NORIHIRO SHIMODA: Hi, nice
to meet you, everyone.
I am Nori, again.
So I'm starting my
new company again.
[LAUGHTER]
So I'll skip this part.
So anyway, fortunately I
could hire a super-real data
scientist this time.
[LAUGHTER]
So it's Yaboo again.
So Yaboo, what can you
do for me this time?
Please tell me the details.
YABOO OYABU: Hi,
everyone, again.
My name is Yaboo, and this
time I'm a real data scientist.
So to make a machine
learning project success,
I think we should several things
to do to keep the [INAUDIBLE]
of our machine learning model.
So let me show you some
critical action items here.
So to make success in
machine learning projects,
first you should define
your criteria, or threshold,
for your machine learning model.
In this case, we
can say we can use
the threshold as our
criteria and the 90% accuracy
as a threshold.
With such metric, we can
check if the machine learning
model works well or not or
good enough to deploy that
to real application.
And the second, we should
keep collecting data
so that we have more and
more unbiased data set
that reflects the real world.
And the last but
not least, we should
keep monitoring the performance
of the machine learning model
so that we can determine
the timing of the deployment
and also retraining of the
machine learning model.
So today-- actually, to
follow these action items,
it's a bit difficult
in real situations.
But today I want to show you
some pretty good dashboards
to follow these action items.
So can you change
to the demo screen?
OK.
This is the data panel
of the dashboard.
So first, let me train
our machine learning
model with trained
data set from day one.
Since it will take some
seconds to finish training,
let me explain how
to use dashboard.
So now you can see the data
set from day one to day 10.
But since this is a
demonstration set-up,
you can see all
the data set now.
But suppose that in a
real-world situation,
the data should be
added every day.
And suppose that we
are now on day one,
so this is a situation where
we are training our machine
learning model with
the latest data set.
So now training
has done, I think.
Yes.
So what is the next step?
As [? Etsuji-san ?] says, the
next step is [? validate our ?]
machine learning model.
So let's switch
to the validation
panel of the dashboard.
Again, you can see all the
data set, but suppose that this
is a demonstration set-up.
So let's assume that
we are on day one.
And the result is--
OK, now 100% accuracy.
So as we said, 90%
accuracy as our threshold
this 100% accuracy is
far beyond our threshold.
So if you like, you can deploy
your machine learning model
to your application
as initial version.
But this 100% accuracy is
sort of an an illusion.
So can you guess
what will happen
if you validate a day-one
machine learning model
with test set from day two.
Let's see.
As you expect, the accuracy is
now going down to around 45%.
So this is really bad and
far below the threshold.
So do you know why this happens?
Yeah, maybe you already know.
So in day-one data set,
there are only digit 0's.
But day-two data set contains
not only 0's but also 1's.
So that's why day-one machine
learning model doesn't work
well on a day-two data set.
So what should you
do in the next step.
Yes, the next step is retraining
your machine learning model.
So now we are on the data
panel and start retraining
our machine learning model with
training data set from day two.
Since it will take
some seconds again,
this time let me explain how
to use the Deploy button here.
So this Deploy button lets
you easily deploy your machine
learning model through
your application.
So let's check how it works in
the application window here.
So now we deployed a day-one
machine learning model.
So this machine learning
model can recognize digit 0.
But as you may expect, this
model cannot recognize digit 1,
as like this.
So now, maybe-- yeah,
training is done.
So what will happen if we click
the Deploy button on day two?
As you expect-- so can
you change to the-- yeah,
thank you.
So now, the application starts
to [LAUGHS] recognize digit 1.
Ooh, yeah.
[LAUGHTER]
[APPLAUSE]
So this Deploy button allows you
to not only deploy your machine
learning model to
your application,
but also roll back the
machine learning model
through your application.
So implementing this
kind of button or command
in your system is very feasible
and practical [INAUDIBLE]
you are driving a real
machine learning project.
Anyway, we finished training the
day-two machine learning model.
The next step is validating
our machine learning model
with latest test set.
OK, now validate our
machine learning model
with test set from day two.
Oh, OK.
[LAUGHS] So now the accuracy
is recovered from 45% to 99%.
This is really great,
and this accuracy
is far beyond our threshold.
So you can now redeploy
your machine learning model
through your application.
But can you guess
what will happen
if we test this machine learning
model with latest data set?
So now suppose we
are on day three.
So what will happen
is the accuracy,
again, is going
down to 66%, 67%.
So in this case,
you should, again,
retrain your machine learning
model with the latest data set.
Actually, in machine
learning project,
you should continue
this process forever
until you shut down
your application.
Well, this is a
very simple example.
But in summary, in a real
machine learning project,
there are three
critical action items.
The first is defining
threshold and criteria
of your machine learning model.
And the second is
continuous data collection.
And the third is
continuous monitoring.
Those action items help
you to make success
in machine learning project.
Thank you.
Back to Etsuji.
ETSUJI NAKAI: OK,
thank you, Yaboo-san.
[APPLAUSE]
OK.
Can you keep your screen
on the demonstration?
OK.
Now, they did a fairly good
job using this demonstration
dashboard.
So let's look back at
what they have done.
On day one, they trained
their machine learning model
with the day-one data and
tested from the same day,
the perfect result.
And the next day they
tested again the same
model with latest data,
tested from day two.
And they realized that
they had some problems--
the accuracy is very bad.
But at least using
this monitoring tool,
they realized they
had a problem,
so they could take action
to recover from it.
They retrained their
machine learning model
with a new data
set from day two,
and then they recovered
accuracy to 99%--
very good.
And next day, they
tested it again,
the latest test
set from day three.
The accuracy became worse again.
However, they can retrain
their machine learning model.
So using this kind of
monitoring dashboard,
they could realize
they had a problem.
That's the value
of this monitoring.
So can you turn back
to the presentation?
As you can see, on
the last day, day 10,
they have 10 machine
learning models,
and they can test against 10
data sets from different days.
There are 10 times 10
equals 100 combinations.
So just for experiment, I
clicked on the Validation
button and saw the result. It
looks a little bit complicated,
but for example, let's
look at the first row.
Those numbers show the accuracy
of the model from day one.
Apparently, the accuracy is
going down straightforwardly.
So if they didn't have
this monitoring tool,
what happens if they kept using
this machine learning model
forever?
It is a tragedy, disaster.
So the lesson is, in
a sense, very simple.
If you don't have this
kind of monitoring tool,
if you don't update your machine
learning model with fresh data,
your model will be
obsolete, definitely.
And you can learn one
more interesting thing
with these numbers.
Let's look at the numbers
on the diagonal line.
This shows the
recovered accuracy.
First day, they achieved a
perfect result. Next day,
they recovered accuracy to 99%.
On third day, they
recovered accuracy to 98%.
Interestingly, this
recovered accuracy is also
slightly decreasing.
It looks like this
on the bar chart.
And as you remember, perhaps,
he set the 90% accuracy
as a threshold.
It means they don't want to
use the machine learning model
if the accuracy
is less than 90%.
In that sense, they have
a problem on the last day,
day 10.
The recovered accuracy on day
10 is slightly less than 90%.
It's a problem for them.
They have to do something to
recover from this situation.
So let me explain first why this
slight decreasing had happened.
It is the data complexity.
As you know, every day they
keep collecting new data.
They have more and
more complex data.
And if their initial
model was very simple,
it could handle the very
simple first-day data.
But it may be really
hard for the simple model
to deal with very complex
data on the last day.
So basically what
they have to do
is just redesign their
machine learning model
if they are using
neural network,
they could add some more layers
to make the machine learning
model more complex to deal
with more complex data.
So this is a
summary of the flow.
On the top left, first
you build your machine
learning model and
train with initial data.
And you keep monitoring
every day, or every week,
and if necessary, you retrain
your machine learning model.
And sometimes you recover the
accuracy above the threshold.
And sometimes you cannot
recover the accuracy even after
the retraining.
In that case, it is
really good timing
for your project to redesign
your machine learning model.
You hire the real
data scientist again.
They will do some
investigation about the nature
of the current data set.
They will redesign the machine
learning model according
to the current data set.
OK, now I think you have
some basic idea what
is the process of the
continuous deployment.
And finally, I will
invite Kazu-san
from our machine learning
partner in Tokyo.
He will tell you
his real experience,
how he applied the continuous
deployment in his real project.
Please welcome
Kazu-san on the stage.
[APPLAUSE]
TAKETOSHI KAZUSA: Hi.
Good to see you.
I'm Kazu from BrainPad, which
is a GCP partner in Japan.
We have about 80 data
scientists in Tokyo.
And we have developed
many, many systems
in a wide variety of industries
for more than 10 years.
One of our customer's
cases, Kewpie,
was featured in
Google Cloud Next '17.
Kewpie is a manufacturer
of food products.
Their mayonnaise is very
popular in many countries.
They operate machine
learning technology
to detect bad potato cubes
in their production line.
We implemented a data system
with a TensorFlow for them.
OK, let's turn back to the
main topic of this session.
I'd like to talk about
another customer case
where we implemented the
continuous deployment
for machine learning systems.
I'd like to explain why the
continuous deployment is
so important for ML models.
Unfortunately, the data of this
customer case are confidential.
So I'll tell some essential
aspects of [INAUDIBLE] what
I learned from this real case.
The customer is logistics
service provider.
They develop clients'
products [INAUDIBLE]
their warehouses to
clients' outlets.
So we help them to apply data
science and machine learning
to optimize the delivery route
and minimize the delivery cost.
Here's our solution.
First, we implemented a machine
learning model [INAUDIBLE]
as demand forecast
for each product
using the data from
the CRM systems.
And then we've
applied another model
which calculates the best
delivery route, the best
on this demand forecast.
OK, so due to the
[INAUDIBLE] system,
our client saved about
$2 million per year.
So let's focus on the continuous
deployment of this demand
forecast model.
The diagram shows that
the continuous deployment
system in our client's case.
First, we retrained the
model on a weekly basis.
Due to the change
in the market, it
is not possible to use
the same model more
than [INAUDIBLE],, so we
introduced the retraining
process on a regular basis.
Sometimes the performance
model is under the threshold
even after retraining.
In such a situation,
Our ML engineers
tried to modify the model itself
to keep the model performance
well.
We [? developed ?] kind
of a monthly report,
which is [? about ?]
model performance,
so our client can understand
what we are doing.
OK, this is the process of this
continuous [? deployment ?]
[INAUDIBLE] help clients.
And then [INAUDIBLE] details.
[INAUDIBLE],, the
freshness of the data
is very important to keep
the model performance well.
In this client's case,
the [INAUDIBLE] data
has a very strong
seasonality and is influenced
by some other external events.
So the retraining
with fresh data
is a very good way to keep
up with these changes.
It is also important to
monitor the model performance
by comparing demand forecast and
actual result. In most cases,
in my experience, this
retraining process
works very well.
So it would be a good idea
to automate [? just ?]
repeatable processes.
But sometimes it doesn't work.
Even after training, the model
performance could be very bad.
In such a situation,
ML engineers
look into the original CRM
data and other data sources
to find out what's
happening in real market.
Typically this kind of a
performance degradation
is caused by drastic
change in the input data.
It is influenced by competitors'
promotions or a new product
launch, and so on.
After finding root causes
of this degradation,
ML engineers think
about how they
can modify the model future
to keep up with these changes.
As you can imagine,
this investigation
is very hard to standardize.
But at least we are
building a dashboard
to help ML engineers to work on
this investigation [INAUDIBLE]..
Finally, let me talk
about risk management.
One of [INAUDIBLE]
in this process
is that there is no guarantee
that ML engineers can
[INAUDIBLE] model performance
in a timely manner.
There might be a data
collapse in our data pipeline,
and the model cannot make
meaningful predictions for why.
This is sort of a
nightmare scenario,
and we should have a backup
plan for such a situation.
In this client's case,
we defined a kind
of a feedback plan with
clients in a very early stage
of this project.
If ML model doesn't
work at all, our clients
switch back to the
manual operation.
Of course, in this
operation there
is no machine learning model.
And then, so our clients
use demand forecast,
which is from a human
planner, and then he
used the statistical approach
to make this demand forecast.
OK, this is what I want to talk.
And then I'll talk.
So I will note that the
customer case of this case
are very simplified.
Actually, in my project we have
a much more complex process
and metrics.
But anyway, the most important
thing in production environment
is how quickly we can take this
kind of performance degradation
and how quickly we can fix it.
We are now building a general
platform to help ML engineers.
Of course, it's
streamlining these kind
of processes, including
monitoring and retraining
[INAUDIBLE] model
and the deployment.
So I will hope
this platform will
be used in many machine learning
projects for our clients.
Thank you.
ETSUJI NAKAI: Thank
you, Kazusa-san.
[APPLAUSE]
OK, so through his
real experience,
I think you have some
realistic image what
is a continuous deployment
in a real project.
so now, as a summary,
let me talk a little bit
about the platform for
the continuous deployment.
As Kazu-san told us,
he's now thinking
about designing some
standardized platform,
or general platform, for
the end-to-end machine
learning, including the
continuous deployment process.
And I think this is really
the frontier of the machine
learning project.
Some customers and partners
are realizing the importance
of the continuous
deployment, and most of them
are thinking about
what is best practice,
what is the best platform,
to support that process?
And we, Google, is the same.
Recently we released
a paper called "TFX."
It is and end-to-end
machine learning platform
used by Google in
[INAUDIBLE],, including
the continuous deployment.
Some of our machine
learning services
are actually learning
on this platform.
Unfortunately, this
platform itself
is not an external service.
You cannot use this
platform as a GCP service.
But at least the good news is
that some essential components
used in this TFX is available
as a part of TensorFlow.
You can see this
paper for details.
So in theory you can
combine TensorFlow
with some standard GCP
products and components
to build your own continuous
deployment platform.
And for today's demonstration,
I combined TensorFlow
with some standard
GCP components
to build that
demonstration dashboard.
However, please be careful.
These specific components
are not important.
These are just for the
sake of demonstration,
especially depending on the
requirements of your project's
functional or
non-functional requirements,
these components
could be different.
The important thing
is to understand
the general framework.
And I think most end-to-end
machine learning platforms now
have three components on the
bottom side of this chart.
First, you need
some data platform
to collect the trend data from
the business data pipeline.
And then you have some training
platform, like Cloud Machine
Learning Engine, to train your
model with these training data.
And finally, you have
some serving platform
to deploy the training
machine learning model
to the real world.
However, to [? realize ?] the
continuous deployment practice,
you need one
additional component--
that is a validation
platform on the top side.
With this validation
platform, you
keep monitoring the accuracy
of your machine learning model.
And ideally, this platform
has some visualization too.
With these
visualizations, you can
understand the trend of the
accuracy of your machine
learning model and
then figure out
the best timing to retrain
your machine learning model
or redesign your
machine learning
model by [? hiring ?]
data scientists again.
And also, it should have
some automation mechanism
like today's demonstration.
Just with a single click,
you can retrain your machine
learning model.
With just a single
click, you can
redeploy your machine learning
model to the real world.
So this is a sort
of call for action.
If you're now working on some
realistic real machine learning
project and want to apply
the continuous deployment
in your project,
please let's start
to have a discussion
with your team members
to think about what is
the most important feature
in your continuous
deployment platform.
What is the best monitoring
dashboard for your project?
OK, in that sense, I want to
ask one additional question
to Kazu-san.
Kazu-san, are you still here?
TAKETOSHI KAZUSA: Hi, I'm here.
ETSUJI NAKAI: Thank you.
OK, my question
is that he told us
that now he's planning to
design his own machine learning
platform, including the
continuous deployment
for customers of his company.
So what do you think is
the most important feature
of the machine learning
platform for your customers.
TAKETOSHI KAZUSA:
OK, that question
is a little bit
complex for me, so I'd
like to answer this
question in Japanese.
ETSUJI NAKAI: OK, no problem.
I will translate.
TAKETOSHI KAZUSA:
[SPEAKING JAPANESE]
Sorry about my Japanese.
ETSUJI NAKAI: OK,
that's no problem.
I think he talked a
really important topic.
So it's really my challenge
to translate it accurately.
OK, basically he told me
that the most important thing
in machine learning
project is to evaluate
the performance of the model in
a real business context using
the real business data.
It means in today's
demonstration,
we simply tested the trained
model against the test set.
But in his project, as he
talked in his presentation,
he compared the
actual business output
against the model's predictions.
So for that, he needs to combine
the business data pipeline
with the machine
learning pipeline,
because he needs very fresh
business outcome data.
It doesn't make any sense if he
evaluates the performance weeks
or months later.
Ideally, he must evaluate
the result in real time
with real-time business data.
So the challenge
is how to combine
these two platforms, business
platform and machine learning
platform.
So his idea does he
wants his platform
to be capable of integrating
with business data
pipeline with a machine
learning pipeline.
I think now it is a very
common understanding
that synchronizing business
data with machine learning
to collect our training
data in a timely manner
is very important.
But he told me that it is
also important to synchronize
the evaluation data from
the business data platform.
OK, that's really a good lesson.
Thank you very much, Kazu-san.
TAKETOSHI KAZUSA:
Thank you very much.
[APPLAUSE]
ETSUJI NAKAI: OK.
Yeah, it's surprising.
I really learned a new
thing in this presentation
from Kazu-san.
And I think it is really
useful for your project too.
And unfortunately, I
don't have much time
to talk about details, more
details, in a Q&A session.
But basically, I'm
really happy to have
further discussion in person
with you if you really like.
So this is announcement--
today's afternoon we have
a event called Cloud Hero.
This is a sort of
DevOps competition.
I'm not sure whether you can
still register in this event
or not, But at least
I will be there.
I would be attending this event.
So if you want to
talk to me in person,
please find me at the venue of
this event in this afternoon.
OK, that's all.
Thank you very much.
[APPLAUSE]
[MUSIC PLAYING]